the last time we all hung out mark was  with us after the fight you remember we  went to the fight and we sat down at a  great steak restaurant  for this you get the tomahawk yes  everybody else looks at the menu and  they look at the most expensive thing  and they go i'll just do one below that  out of respect for joe who's going to  pay for this dinner oh  what are you doing and then joe goes oh  the tomahawk and then mark doesn't even  wait for the waiter to come over he goes  double it up  it's a good move okay i don't see where  there's a problem thank you expensive  steak going buying steaks for people  gives a [ __ ] now mark was a little  disappointed that you didn't finish your  steak bro okay all right i didn't say  like that you did say it like that you  [ __ ] people have the weirdest things  you focus on  how much a steak cost and then how much  did you eat  i can't wait a month to talk about this  [Music]  [ __ ]